brother grant how are we doing i'm 26
getting married in june and i have a
two-year-old daughter
of my own and my fiance has a
three-year-old daughter
and um kids seem a little overwhelming
to me at times and
you know i have two and i have one and a
half as i like to say and so i
i want to know how do i be a you know
how do i be a great husband how do i be
a great dad
um and how do i be a great stepdad um
it all kind of just seems overwhelming
at times yeah yeah i'd say dude
it's overwhelming for sure man um
i just want to stop the show for a
second man and just tell you i
appreciate you
and i love your heart brother and um
thinking ahead if every man would just
stop and pause and say
this is a lot and i want to be good at
this and i want to do this right
and i want to pick up some tools early
on man good for you man good for you
for setting an example for um your kids
and for every guy who's listening to
this thing
every guy listening listen to grant be
that guy
okay all right so two-year-old of your
own
uh a three-year-old of your own
two-year-old coming in with a fiance is
that right
two-year-old of my own three-year-old
coming in with a fiancee both girls
okay 26 what do you do for a living man
i work in aviation so i uh
i manage like ground handling of like
aircraft
oh she like know how to do a thing
unlike me who just runs his mouth for a
living that's pretty awesome
okay so tell me what happened in with
um baby mama with you the mother of your
daughter
man you want you want the whole story
she wants a short story
give me the short one so i met her in
college
i was going to college um met her
we dated for five years um
we had an abortion um kind of dark part
of my life
um and when i tried to end things
um ended up having a baby um and so
i tried to kind of make things work you
end relationships way different than i
used to but go ahead yeah
yeah a little bit of a surprise but
anyway he says
you know pretty dramatic part of my life
kind of stressful part of my life but um
so anyways uh my daughter came into the
world tried to make things work and i
just realized
you know at the end of the day me
marrying somebody that i'm not happy
with is way worse than
you know uh being the best dad i can be
to her and us
not being married um so i see her a
couple times a week
um i have a pretty good relationship
with with her mom
i'm not the best at times she's somebody
that kind of struggles with some
some mental maybe instability uh she's
just had her own past and so um but i i
have a i have a good relationship not a
not a great relationship like i said i'd
like it to be better but a good
relationship
with her um yeah and
tell me why you're getting married to
this new woman
um so she just
she's everything i could hope for and a
partner um i think the thing you know my
parents always told me growing up is oh
when you meet the right person you know
you'll just know that they're the right
person and
i didn't really believe that to be
honest and um this
this woman came into my life and um
everything just
she's so easy to get along with and
she's a christian she shares the same
things as me the same morals as me she
grew up but a pretty much identical uh
you know family life with
with married parents and just siblings
and she has two siblings and i have two
siblings and we just
really get along you know of all the
stress in my day managing people being
around you know
loud airplanes and everything else i
come home to her and it's just it's it's
easy
um it's not easy having a three-year-old
but you know it's
it's um she says she makes me the best
version of me that
that i can be cool so do you still have
a good relationship with your parents
yeah i do um having to have it you know
having a baby out of wedlock
my mom reminds me constantly about how i
send um
so i'm telling you right now no you
don't have a good relationship with your
parents
yeah not as not as great as i would hope
um
no hey that's not a good relationship
with your parents
well maybe maybe your old man but um
geez louise okay
all right so how do you be the best dad
you can be right
right and so here's why i asked you
those questions i want to paint a
picture because every dad's a little
bit different and every dad's bringing
different bricks in their backpack
to this wild adventure of
parenting okay and every dad
has got different things on the table
there's some things that we all need to
be doing in common then there's some
things are going to be very specific to
each one of us okay so i'm going to
rattle a bunch of stuff off here
as i go okay and you can either write
this down or you can just keep this
podcast forever or go onto the youtubes
internets and
cut and paste it and hold on to it okay
okay
here's number one um you've got to love
your new wife you have to model it you
have to love her
like crazy okay
this relationship is about you and your
new wife
this relationship is about y'alls coming
together and being in love and all that
fun stuff
and it's also modeling for these two
young
baby girls what it looks like to be
treated by somebody who loves you
okay so you'll be a walking
a walking college course to your baby
girls
on this is what love looks like this is
what i deserve
this is what somebody who says the words
i love you this is what they do
so you have to go out of your way to
love that woman like
crazy okay
my guess is by the way your mom talks to
you and
the challenges you've had in the past
you're gonna need some skills
some new skills that's not a bad thing i
don't know many guys who don't need new
skills when they enter into
relationships
okay um that we'll talk about that in a
second so number two
is never ever ever talk bad about your
the mother of your girl don't ever talk
bad about the
ex husband ex the father of
what's soon to be you know your fiance's
baby girl and your
baby girl number two okay you're
modeling
here's what relationships look like
here's what reconciliation looks like
here's what people who have had
challenges in the past here's how they
treat each other with dignity and
respect
count on problems over the years
count on there to be struggles there to
be custody issues count on all of that
decide before you get married decide
before you take on another daughter into
your
into your world i'm gonna be this type
of person
i'm not gonna go to war i'm not gonna
yell i'm gonna do what's right
right and i'm gonna um if there's
injustice i'm going to be right there in
the middle of it but i'm going to do it
with dignity and do with respect
right um number three say i love you
every single solitary day of these young
girls lives
and hold their face and say it into
their eyeballs so they can see you
okay there will be days when they don't
want to hear it they're gonna be like no
dad matt they're gonna say
i don't care you will hear the words out
of my mouth every day that
i love you right high touch
high touch and here's a a key and i'm i
got a five-year-old daughter and so i'm
wrestling with this right now and it's
hard for me
but i i think i'm getting it right and
that is this
and sometimes my wife has to say ah i'm
like oh no i knew it okay
it's this it's really high touch with
autonomy
what does that mean that means i want my
daughter
to know that i love her more than
anything and i also want her to know
i want a teacher at a young age that she
is in control of her
body what does that mean on on the
ground
that means i might say hey come give
your daddy a hug
and she'll say no daddy because she's
being silly
or no daddy i don't want to hug you i
can then say
i told you to come give me a hug or i
can run over there and grab her and
force her to what am i telling her
that at some point some guy who's bigger
and stronger
can say no you will love me and it will
look like this
and i ultimately because i have bigger
stronger muscles i'm in control of your
body
and i don't want her to ever feel that
so i'm teaching her at a young age
she's in control of her body i'm not
going to weaponize my love i'd say hey
baby
come snuggle with dad and she says no i
want to sit over here
from that point forward it's about me i
want her to come snuggle with me she
doesn't want to
i gotta go cool hope you're having fun
over there on that side of the couch and
then i'm gonna go about watching my show
because i'm not gonna i'm not gonna get
into it right
but it's about high touch with autonomy
and what i'll tell you is
saying i love you every day they can be
tough and silly but me when it comes to
bedtime when it comes to
quiet time when it comes to reading
stories and we read stories to our kids
every single night of the week
man that touch comes man they crave it
they just want to fall into it and so
it's letting it happen naturally
sometimes i got to go to bed and be like
well my daughter hates me
she doesn't she's being five right um
get on the floor and wrestle with these
little girls let them know that you care
about them
act interested in dragons and ponies and
baby dolls and frogs and trucks and
hammers whatever the thing is
make that the most exciting important
thing when you're down on the ground
with them
don't go down there with your cell phone
right take care of yourself
eat right exercise have friends model
what friendship looks like
last two things are you ready yep be
really slow with advice
and really long on presence
most dads love to love their daughters
by telling them info well you know what
you should do is
this i would if i was you i would go do
this thing
oh you need to tell that teacher that
guy that ah
man most of us our daughters are really
really really smart and intuitive
what they really need is us to get down
on a knee and look them in the eye and
say
i love you and i'm so sorry that
happened that stinks
or oh my goodness i can't wait to see
that dragon come show it to me again
or sure i'll put my phone down and read
you this book right here in the middle
of the living room floor let's just do
it right here
that tells a young girl i matter i've
got value my daddy loves me
and the last thing is this often guys
dads
they will be great fathers they'll
they'll do their best they'll plug in
and then they'll go work on their car
then they'll go
get the oil change then they'll go to
the bank they'll go do these other
things that unfortunately have been
gendered and domesticated right this is
what guys do and this is what girls do
as many places you can possibly take
those two girls take him with you
take him to help you make him get out of
the car with you
if you gonna go play catch bring him
along with you if you're going to a
buddies house help mow the lawn bring
them along with you
let them be involved in the day-to-day
rhythms of your
life no matter how quote unquote boy of
a job it is i just hate all that crap
bring him along with you bring them
hunting bring them fishing
bring them everywhere with you um if you
play call of duty just stop playing
video games but other than that bring
them with you right
ah there you go you're my man grant
bring them with you
and just set up your life to where your
buddies know hey when i go out
um my daughters are coming with me
because i love them and they're awesome
and they're rad
and they will get to watch dad have
friends they'll get to watch
who dad really is and that will
shape-shift everything about their life
and then the last last last thing i
already said the last thing i got one
more thing
okay how how bold do you want to be
brother how good of a dad you want to be
bold and courageous all right i want you
to go see a counselor for your trauma i
want you to go see somebody
have you i well so i wanted to
it's kind of a side note so i did see
counselors through the
you know the traumatic stuff with with
my baby mama
um but i just you had said a while back
you know universities have
uh you know counselors and trainings
reach out to you practice labs whatever
so i reached out beginning of the year
and they paired me up with this guy
um and the first counselor i had was a
girl but they paired me up with the one
i had a couple years ago but the
the the student one that i have is a guy
and i met with him yesterday for the
first time in person
um because i got my kovach shot and they
they're letting us like meet
face-to-face and so anyways
um i just i don't know i don't really
seem to click with him um
and i just i don't know do i keep going
to him dr john or
do i just stop it now like i usually
recommend folks go two or three times
and if you don't click you don't click
and then you move on
don't judge him by how tall he is or how
much hair he's got or
how high or low his voice is or anything
like that um
be as vulnerable as you can okay be open
and vulnerable tell the truth
the whole truth all of it even with me
just now i'm not calling you alive i'm
saying like
like hey how's your relationship with
your parents they're great my mom
reminds me what a
what a failure i am right so be honest
about your past your childhood the stuff
your parents expected of you the way
they still beat you up even though
you're 26 with almost two kids
all those things be honest in these
sessions give this
well john john one thing that he said
was
you know i went and saw this counselor
for two years and i never really
like i couldn't even tell you i don't
know what her husband's name was you
know like and obviously it's i'm not
there to be friends like you talk about
but
you know i said i'd like to little know
a little bit more about you because
you know he's like 28 29. i said where
are you from
um you know where'd you go where'd you
get your undergrad and like he said well
you're making me uncomfortable grant and
like why are you asking me this and
and i understand where he's coming from
like you know they
obviously got to protect yourself as a
professional but on the flip side i said
well i want to be able to relate
you know i feel like you know i listen
to you every week like i relate to you
yeah um or do you think that's
irrelevant john
like yeah i think um my guess is
that's a
go in there to get some help and not to
build bridges
okay um yeah counselors are trained not
to make it about them
and usually when somebody starts digging
into their past
where'd you go to school why are you
doing this where are you from how many
kids do you have
um that's usually about the
the the patient the clients trying to do
some distancing trying to get some
things there
um take some ownership of that
relationship man you're in there to
learn some skills and to get well the
the relationship matters for sure um but
i wouldn't go in there asking a bunch of
questions i'd go in there ready to go
okay go in there ready to go trust this
person wouldn't be in there if they
didn't know what they were doing
and if you get in and you just don't
feel comfortable man ask for another
therapist
it's simple this is about you you're not
in there to make a therapist feel good
about themselves they're grown up big
boys and girls
if a client says i don't want to work
with you because i'm not feeling a
connection
sweet we're moving on to the next thing
same thing here
you go find somebody that you're
connected to okay make that a priority
but yeah don't go in there asking a
bunch of questions about their family
and things like that it doesn't matter
it's not relevant you think that's gonna
help you build a relationship it's not
it's a stalling technique it's a punting
technique
um for you to make sure you've got
control that situation part
of counseling is going there and being
vulnerable and
i'm just going to lay it all out here in
a safe space this person said they're
not going to judge me this person's
going to walk alongside me
go in there and just put it all down
okay go in there and put it all down
um grant the fact that you're asking
these questions tells me you're going to
be a good guy
a good dad go in there ready to rock and
roll keep this
little video clip with you tell those
girls you love them
be connected to them and us above all
else
do your work on yourself and love love
love their mom show that mom that you
love her every day